getting someone to make a new habits  incredibly difficult getting someone to  break a habit is incredibly difficult  and so we just want to piggyback on  habits they already have what you want  to do is give someone a vision of what  their life's going to be like when  they're experiencing the benefits want  to explain to them exactly how to take  it before you make the ask this one is  going to help you do benefit benefit the  way that I need you to take it need you  to take it I want you to put it next to  your toothbrush so we don't have to make  a new habit we want to figure out ways  to associate the usage of the product  with something they're already doing